um twitter is working on a new
subscription-based platform codenamed
griff griffin griffin um and
griffin yeah um and i had talked about
this a while ago i said they just pay
100 bucks a year and let everybody be
verified or five bucks a month and
they'd have a great revenue stream and
then you could just click a button and
say
i only want to see people who pay and
anybody else will just be grayed out or
you know i could filter them out just
like the quality filter
um to our uh wednesday morning twitter
posted a job listing revealing they're
building a new internal
team codename griffin that is building a
subscription platform
and this is just like the easiest layout
for alex and journalists like
do you not think journalists are reading
your job descriptions oh my lord that's
just like the easiest hack in the world
right alex yep
that i mean when i saw this i was like
come on guys come on guys come on
you can't announce your secret project
in a thing we're going to go read like
come on we're going to see
for test drivers and right driving
it's like for a special project that is
not a self-driving car
um and the uh popular theories right now
is that it's a twitch patreon style
subscription which would be quite nice
actually uh you so you could
subscribe to individual accounts and uh
that would be amazing for people to be
able to monetize themselves
i talked to evan williams about that a
decade ago
or power users could pay for access to
new analytics breaking news alerts stuff
like that
um twitter share price jumped 12
um which is pretty amazing since people
have kind of lost face
in that company ever breaking out
against uh the goliath um
what would i guess the first question
alex
um would you pay for twitter and if you
would pay for twitter
what features top three
in ranked order would you want to pay
for uh it's a great question one
absolutely i've been on twitter since
2007 2008 and i've
i still use it as much as i did 10 years
ago which is a shocking
thing to say out loud but i'm still as
attached to it
so whatever they want to charge me i
would have to pay cause i can't not have
it so they could charge me
an infinite amount of money i would go
broke cause i'd have to give it to them
uh things that i would love i would love
to be able to support
individual publications and bans on
twitter i think it'd be really fun to be
able to
follow say you know blavity or tc or
whatever or a band that i love that's
smaller
and be able to give them some money on a
recurring basis it'd be fun to have that
mechanism
yeah i would love to pay to not see
advertisements i'm
always willing to do that wait are you
verified do you see ads
i don't i see smoke it spikes though
right guys i mean like because
sometimes there's no ads they're
promoted tweets when you go to a feed
yeah but i assume morgan are you
verified you got blue check mark
yeah i'm verified yeah we're all team
verified but
in the beginning team verify didn't see
any ads that was their election
like no we got to charge those guys yeah
they're like it's great until
they realize that's where all their
money is yeah well now we see them in
big bursts before earnings i feel so
that's what happens on that so get rid
of ads and then a last thing
i don't know those are the only two
things that i want i would pay money to
not have an edit button
for everyone else to get spicy about
that ooh morgan what do you what do you
got would you pay for it
i would have to pay for it on the
business side it's critical for
black news and real stories and truth
telling
um on the personal level as a personal
brand i hate twitter
um i feel constantly attacked
and it is not a positive place anymore
for me
um what is the nature of
a black woman on twitter
how what what do you experience
you know i i used to tweet a lot
and now i have the fear that at one
point when i was
21 years old you know tipsy in college
tweeted something silly and that people
are going to go back
and do the whole cancel thing you know
um and i'll be like yeah she was done
but that was 10 years ago
yeah you know um and then and i wasn't a
public figure
right no um i was just me my 200
followers
so you know i i have definitely tried to
go back and like delete archive just
make sure
luckily i didn't have anything that bad
to delete um but i just worry about
the trolls and the people who are just
angry
and sitting on their couch just sitting
there with nothing to do
but all they have to do is tweet some
provocative stuff
some provocative hashtag and all of a
sudden it just spins into this little
weird cycle of mean and toxicity
it's pretty crazy and toxic i guess the
question next question i have for each
of you is
i'm going to propose a price let's
assume there's a free tier
and you get almost everything but you
know there's some
premium features uh
50 100 i'm sorry five dollars a month
ten dollars a month fifteen dollars a
month
which price do you think they're going
to go with if you had to pick one
netflix price
ten dollars a month okay alex i think i
think that's right but i just realized i
have an idea about why they're doing
this jason
um you've been tracking sas stocks i
presume like everyone else has been
because software prices have gone
through the roof
twitter is an ads business and everyone
doesn't love an ad business if it's not
google or facebook so i bet twitter just
wants some gosh darn recurring revenue
and that's going to juice their
evaluation nicely
so from a financial perspective it's
smart but i would pay 15 or
1500 if they demanded me to pay it
because i can't not have it you're a
super user though
absolutely i'm guilty of charge i mean i
don't feel great about this but i'm
trying to be as honest as i can be on
the show i'm not particularly cool and i
do tweet too much so this is uh this is
my world you know this is where i hang
out with my
my collection of weird goofball friends
so uh yeah i
i think the analytics part uh and some
of the premium features that you use
third party for so the feature i've been
asking them for is archive so
you know on on instagram you can archive
your old stuff i also archived
my entire facebook i had to use a
third-party tool it was like a
a chrome extension i just literally
archived everything because i don't like
to use it
and i don't want people bringing up
pictures of my kids and stuff like that
and
you know you guys uh we've all went from
kind of obscure figures 10 15 years ago
to now being
you know uh you know more notable and so
you do get a little bit of security
concerns or
also you know the way people use twitter
was it was almost like a chat room and
people forget that like
people were tweeting hundreds of times a
day and they were just responding to
each other as if it was a chat room
and so you could find chats that were
like yes
and okay sure you know it's like what
what's this relation to so i archive my
whole thing but i you can't archive so i
just
used some there's some tweet deleting
tool for this 10 bucks a month
and so i downloaded my archive and then
i deleted everything and then
so now i just have my last two years or
something oh that's great
uh yeah it's kind of cool you can just
type in twit tweet deleter and then
there are some people now
who just say every thousand tweets
just keep the last thousand or just keep
the last hundred days whatever it is
like your imessages
is the imessage does that you're saying
yeah i didn't know that feature exists
so anyway
it's kind of a cool thing and that's
what i would pay for also the analytics
you know people pay for buffer or
analytics
tweet deck all that stuff that
businesses use
man there's so many great things they
could use and we were investors in a
company called get little bird
that got sold and
they did a very interesting thing which
was like they would create twitter lists
automatically so you'd say hey
you know give me everybody in you know
involved in sushi and sushi restaurants
and you'd say okay give me 10 sushi
related
twitter candles and then it would go out
and do the cross-referencing and say who
do these handles follow in common okay
that's the second degree
it'll kind of do a bit of page ranking
and there's so many amazing
ideas there